.
CAN CASH IN ON SATURDAY NIGHT,
RIGHT HERE ON FOX AND YOU HAVE
TO SEE THIS GREAT SHOW.
AND HISTORIC HIGHS, HISTORIC
SURGES EVEN GOING TO GET BIGGER
BECAUSE THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ABOUT TO
REMOVE THE BORDER ERROR POLICY
AND TITLE 42 WHICH ALLOWS THE
INSTANT DEPORTATION OF MIGRANTS
AT THE BORDER.
THE FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR STEVEN
MILLER IS JOINING US NOW AND
THIS IS A NO-BRAINER.
OVERCROWDED, IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
SAYING THAT WE DON'T NEED TO DO
SO BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BE HERE VERY LONG.
WHY WOULD THEY RESEND THIS IN
THE PANDEMIC CONTINUES.
ALREADY AVAILABLE HERE IN NEW
YORK CITY AND IT'S ABOUT TO HIT
THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS THE
PERFECT PLACE FOR NEW VIRUSES AS
WELL AS NEW VARIANCE SPREAD.
PEOPLE ARRIVE AT THE BORDER.
CRAMMED INTO TRUCKS AND CARS,
TRACTOR-TRAILERS, PILED ON TOP
OF EACH OTHER, SHARING THE SAME
ERROR.
IT IS AS DANGEROUS AS IT CAN GET
AND THAT IS WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP
PUT IN PLACE TITLE 42, THE
UNITED STATES SOUTHERN BORDER.
AS WE SEEK OUT THIS MOMENT WE
ALREADY HAVE 7000 APPREHENSIONS
PER DAY AND AT LEAST 2000 THAT
WE KNOW OF AND MANY MORE THAT WE
DON'T KNOW OF.
OVER 10,000 AT LEAST PER DAY.
INCLUDING WHAT IS LEFT OF TITLE
42 TURNING OUR BORDER, TOTAL
SECURITY OF THE TRUMP ERA TO AN
UTTER NIGHTMARE AND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION APOCALYPSE.
>> YOU KNOW, FOR EXAMPLE, JOE
BIDEN NOT ONLY BROUGHT BACK THE
POLICIES OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, BASICALLY IT IS
A CATCH PROCESS AND A FREE RIDE
TO THE STATE OF YOUR CHOICE.
AND IF I DID THAT OR YOU DID
THAT, I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT
YOU COULD GET ARRESTED FOR
VIOLATING THE IMMIGRATION LAWS
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY PROBABLY
WOULD BE ACCUSED OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AM I WRONG OR RIGHT ON THAT?
AND WE WOULD BE IN JAIL FOR
YEARS.
AND THAT IS A SEVERE CRIMINAL
OFFENSE.
150,000 CHILDREN, SMUGGLED
BECAUSE EVERYBODY GETTING IN.
THE LAST REMAINING SHRED OF
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT IS AN
OPEN BORDER WITH NO LIMITS AT
ALL.
2 CONGRATULATIONS ARE IN ORDER
FOR YOU AND YOU